is the most important week of the
British Prime Minister's tenure and it's
fair to say her battle for brexit has
not got off to the best of starts thus
after Theresa Mays government was found
in contempt of Parliament for the first
time in its history the PM says
Parliament's failure to back her deal
could see the EU exit door slammed shut
in the country's face if you reject what
the other side have described is the
only deal on offer then whatever you say
to the contrary you put this country on
course for No Deal the EU 27 member
states have made it clear that this is
the best deal available and that there
is neither the time nor the inclination
to reopen negotiations and ensure we
leave in good order on the 29th of March
next year the choice the choice before
Parliament is clear this deal no deal or
the risk of no brexit well it has been
an absolutely turbulent time in
Parliament the house has spoken in the
most unprecedented of fashions and
that's as the government has been found
in contempt of parliament now that comes
following in the Commons supporting a
motion demanding full disclosure of the
legal texts on brexit now in theory the
government should be now obliged to
produce that legal text on brexit but
the government responded saying that it
will tell the public and Parliament
alike exactly what it intends to do in
due course
though many say it would be absolutely
unimaginable
if MPs did not get a copy of that text
ahead of the meaningful vote in
Parliament and Tuesday December the 11th
now all of that drama has completely
overshadowed the fact that was supposed
to be the grand old opening of the five
days of the brexit debates but when the
Prime Minister Theresa May finally
managed to speak she was shut down by an
avalanche of MPs criticism the Prime
Minister has seen these negotiations
only as an exercise in the internal
management of the Conservative Party and
that did not work out very well at all
Prime Minister has spent much of it 2
and a half years discussing the deal
with her colleagues on a conservative
party rather
negotiating with the European Union
Prime Minister steel seriously
undermines environmental protection in
this country she is afraid that her
brexit ship would sink 1,000 jobs lost
from the European Banking Authority
1,000 jobs lost from the European
Medicines Agency mr. speaker that's not
project fear that's the reality and it's
already well brexit has entirely divided
the nation for the last two years and it
all boils down to that vote in
Parliament on December the 11th and in
the last two years we've seen many many
difficult stages for the Prime Minister
we've seen resignations from her top
team we've had deadlines come and go
we've had calls for brexit to even be
reversed and ideas and notions that a
second referendum could be on the cards
and even the EU has put options in place
saying that the Britain could actually
remain within the EU but it's really
been pandemonium in Parliament and it's
going to be a very difficult uphill
five-day battle for the Prime Minister
because now it's make or break for her
government we have to remember that this
government has been in contempt of court
and in contempt of the British people I
think that's why for a very long time we
should not forget at the beginning why
we had the referendum on the referendum
it was for the Tories to deal with their
internal states so this government
through all this time through all these
years they showed that they cannot deal
with the situation but also that we
don't really care about the British
people they care about being in power
you